hey hallo ich bin isa b hallo ich bin da
ja aber ich bin auch ihr zukünftiger
ehemann herzlich konsole lotte es ist
wieder so weit die wirklich schlimmste
werbung auf youtube ist zurückgekehrt
wenn ich von der schlimmsten werbung
rede dann rede ich von asta also habe
ich mal mit meinem bruder max zusammen
gemacht dass hier ist auch ein video mit
max zusammen ich muss nur gerade diesen
part nachdrehen weil meine kamera bei
der aufnahme irgendwie abgehakt ist dann
bekennen ich will gar nicht lange drum
rumreden leute hier sind die neuen er
sagt lips kommentiert von max und mir
entschuldigung ich habe meine telefon
verloren kann ich mir dein herz legen
[Musik]
sonst kriegst sondern auch sagen man
kennt das auch dass wir eine
realistische repräsentation von dem was
da passiert attraktive junge mädchen
wissen einfach nicht wie sie an typen
kommen sollen
wir müssen natürlich auch sie werden ja
nicht angesprochen im alltag oder bei
den feiern also nee
die müssen auch versagen aber versagen
dann kommt budget young gurren und gibt
vielleicht eine nummer aus und hätte
versucht was sind deine pläne für heide
haben
netter versuch später versucht sich
wieder ausnutzen seine wie dich ich
denke es ist aber schon mit netter
versuch dachte es mal wieder dass du als
sehr attraktives junges mädchen mit
milchzähnen mit milch sind servicestudie
ich bin weg von meiner schwester du
weißt du wieder schwächster woher kommt
der entweder ich wollte kein deutsch
sprechen wir also wie tassen zu
analysieren was wofür steht er sah es da
steht dafür
es geht wirklich einfach nur um es ja
bekanntlich anders ist wirklich wahr
auch wenn das damals schon gesagt du
willst du willst mich schicken jaja so
kuck mal wisst ihr wenn ihr so irgendwie
auf dubiosen seiten sollten dann steht
attraktive frauen in deiner nähe wollen
wir sind alle aufwachen ja also ich
hätte jetzt alle bitte ich halt einfach
alles aber sei gelingt diese ganzen
werbung singles
natürlich brauchen diese hässlichen
frauen wollen auch das ist ganz so
stellt für mich einfach so frei ist dort
wahrscheinlich für dieses video geld
dann wie youtube kein besser
jetzt ist okay die wenigste werbung
vorführsaal da sind so 10 sollte wird so
hunde massiv und so eine übertrieben
keine domina sagte wird zum knochen alle
rennen so wie tag also das gelbe lack
ist sehr teuer so one on one ist ich
werde jetzt geht zwar gibt loosli
vereinigen die clips sind ja
wahrscheinlich beide einfach mit einer
handykamera aufgenommen und werden dann
gegen geschnitten also jemand kriegt
die liste soll so sagt sehen sie den
satz den satz ohne und die haben einfach
keine millisekunde zur denkpause also
leute war okay wir machen das was er
dann was er dann neben mir der mir diese
komplett cool und abgeklärt klären
checken diese das date up service und
treffen
naja ok das macht natürlich die haben es
gerade eben schon analysiert auch es
sind einfach zu viele geile weiber es
ist einfach so zu viele heiße frauen und
nicht genug
könnte es sein dass die werbung
möglicherweise auf junge männer
ausgerichtet ist damit dir auf diese
bedenken dass sie da nein das hat damit
gar nichts zu tun
man sollte ich auf gar keinen fall
wieder finden in dem typ der da ist ja
also ich kann mich mit dem identifiziere
ich mich ja eigentlich auch das ist
genau der gleiche text weisst du noch
damals
es ist der gleiche text ja es macht euch
ein bisschen arbeit vor dem komma was
ist das für ein ja doch so hey das ist
ganz schön gut aus so etwa james und
keine ganze sekunde angeschaut und kommt
die andere
du machst mich krank so direkte
freundschaft zerstört leben zerstört die
eine hat die mutter von anderen
umgebracht
der andere der tat da ich habe zuerst
gesehen ja wie gesagt leute glaubt
einfach dieser werbung glaubt allgemein
jede werbung aber dort dieser war und
ganz speziell auf as a gibt es einfach
so viele mädels und jungs da draußen
müssen wir vielleicht damen dann seht
ihr wie lange meine haare sehen diese
blockade fürchten alle wie immer unser
beileid geht raus an die leute die
schauspieler sind für solche clips wie
machen sich über euch persönlich lustig
sondern über die person die er darstellt
das ist ein fürchterlicher auf der
rechten seite nicht kennt das ist fährt
riesch maria oder maria steve instagram
und die hat bei kras klassenfahrt
mitgespielt ist dass sie frau ostermann
ja das ist tatsächlich die sich auf der
gamescom getroffen sondern wissen wieder
gestreikt
random alter und jetzt in der werbung
zur kenntnis wer sich so computer
begrüßungs mensch begrüßt weiblich zur
kenntnis genommen witze erzählen
du brauchst du dir auf der game schon
getroffen sondern uns gegenseitig zeit
hin
weißt du glaubst du was zu tun und ist
das aber und ja wer zuerst lag der
verhehlt auto gut ich fange an die hat
schon die hat schon eingesetzt zu reden
hatte ich sage jetzt einfach froh ist
wenn man noch nicht zu ende gesprochen
so ist hast du das ich gerade sie links
ist halt ein cyborg das weiß jeder
und sie hatten eine künstliche
intelligenz mit der sie schon vorher die
satz enden voraussagen kann um schneller
zu beantworten damit man unter 23
sekunden sagte dr
ich habe mir jeden tag in sieben uhr
morgens ich will es gar nicht wissen wie
dieser witz weiter geht also wieder
richtig böse wort von mir
sie ist so großartig
ja ich mache erst um 7 uhr 30 auf
kopfschuss zwei millionen klicks ja aber
aber echte also die sind ja nicht
gekauft hat ist auch keine werden aber
die bürger haltung zeigen auch dass es
ja stellen das maximieren kleiner so
jeder klassiker leute zwei millionen
klicks 33 was ich halt viel schlimmer
findet zwei millionen klicks sind nicht
günstig das ist richtig viel geld also
auch soeben wurde ich weiß was das
kostet sagen wir einen klick vier cent
kostet es glaube ich ungefähr das sind
1000 klicks 40 euro ja tausend klicks 40
euro und sind einfach mal 2040 80.000
euro da wird es dieses video von noch
üblichen kann sich das lohnen vor allen
dingen für 80.000 euro braucht gibt mir
tausend euro ich mache euch eine geile
werbung
dann könnt ihr immer noch 79.000 euro da
rein ballern wieso so aber achte mal
auch im gesicht auf der rechten seite so
das eklige an den witz ist noch gar
nicht gesagt und sie ekelt sich schon
geisteskrank chapter doping ich hab
nicht durchgegangen jeden tag um die uhr
morgens großartig sagt das ist großer
die geometrie so großartig war das
eklige heute bin allergisch gegen das
wort großartig
ja sagt der patienten wieder so ein
patient sagt ja das ist für die
krankheit sondern auch durch die straßen
seiner später was machen ja aha aber ich
muss wirklich sagen ich bin jetzt gerade
ein bisschen verwirrt ich dachte wow er
sagt etwas anderes so ich werde warten
lässt
er stimmt der frauen dürfen hat nicht
sechster plattform die müssen sich die
trend nicht hilft müssen sich witze
erzählen oder dürfen wenn die beiden
sich aber wenn sich die beiden aber
treffen würden dann irgendwie zusammen
mit einem typen fest also und würden
sich dann um ihn streiten
so ist es hey hallo hallo ich bin da ich
aber ich bin auch ihr zukünftiger
ehemann politisches touren die neuen
team habe ich hier den play playdead
erfahren sie wie ladys war jeder clown
kann wenn man so eine frau ich bin max
ich heute abend
hey hallo hallo ich bin da wo ich bin
ich bin da wollen muss ich einfach mal
treffen
ja das würde mich freuen dann kann ich
denn meine sammlung von porzellan clowns
zeigen hey das ist schon frank man muss
sagt man muss eine sache sagen vieles
was bei asa in der werbung ist ist nicht
realitätsgetreue aber der typ würde mit
diesen sprüchen ja es gibt draußen leute
und es tut mir leid das zu sagen es gibt
in deutschland leute die sowas machen
solche leute die solche ansprüche haben
ja ich kann dir meine
briefmarkensammlung zeigen was das würde
mich freuen dann kann ich denn meine
sammlung von porzellan clowns zeigen das
ist die liebe
hallo ich bin einfach nur noch sauer
ohne witz ich bin sauer und verwirrt und
sowas soll eine lehrerin seien ja toll
wie kann man sich so vorbildhaft
verhalten und gleichzeitig lehrerin
seien nicht das was man uns heute heute
wenn ihr in zukunft welche werbung haben
die draußen sollen das hat mir einen
drauf ins du gerne hier unter das video
ich lässig kommentare bleibt immer gut
wir warten auf die nächste asa werbung
dann sehen wir uns wieder damen damen